costco has stopped stalking
excuse me my pillow products my pillow
ceo mike lindell is uh furious about
this now if you don't know who mike
lindell is congratulations you've
avoided one of the most
toxic elements of the last year of the
news
mike lindell is a uh ceo of a company
called mypillow he sells pillows mostly
on right wing tv
and radio at the beginning of the
pandemic he was front
and center because donald trump invited
him to the white house to announce that
he would be
retooling some of his factories to
produce masks rather than pillows
when we tried to actually figure out how
many masks did they really produce
it's unclear but it seems the number is
extraordinarily low
mike lindell at that point started
talking about how trump is a gift from
god to the united states
and generally went completely off the
deep end after the november election
mike lindell was one of the primary
promulgators on newsmax and fox news and
other channels
of completely baseless conspiracy
theories about the election
and uh with all sorts of claims
including recently that donald trump
will be resuming power i believe he said
in august or something like that
so this guy is completely off the rails
and as a result
because we have you know a sort of free
market and businesses can decide what to
do
some retailers have decided to stop
selling my
my pillow pillows and uh
before costco made the decision kroger
had already done the same lindell now
says
at least 22 retailers have stopped
selling
his pillows since january and that
includes
sam's club and kohl's and bed bath and
beyond
mike lindell has also announced that he
will be launching a new online
store to compete against amazon in
reality
it seems that he's launching an online
store to sell the pillows that lots of
retailers aren't selling he said this
the other day
because i'm looking at another thing
we're going to be launching which is my
store
which is a rival to amazon pretty uh
pretty explosive stuff right now i have
to tell you
i have never been to a costco in my life
i think you need a membership to shop
there
i've never had one okay between costco
paying better wages than lots of other
retailers
and dropping my pillow this is sounding
like a place i'm going to have to
investigate maybe i should be shopping
at costco
lindell is blaming costco's decision
on so-called cancel culture this
is actually called when you do things
other things happen
it's a free market everybody gets to
speak
speech can sometimes have consequences
and
not selling someone's pillows is
protected speech it's a business
decision that businesses can make
no one's rights have been violated no
one has had
their membership in a protected class
used
to discriminate against them or to deny
them something
by cancel culture what it really is
are the consequences of a free
enterprise
where people can decide what to say and
what to do
for themselves that's all that this is
and this also gets back to what i said
on monday i believe it was
about people no longer understand
sorry many people no longer understand
or never understood
what counts as a fact and what counts
as an opinion mike lindell isn't getting
dropped
by costco and others for opinions
he's being dropped because he's
spreading demonstrably
false statements about facts we call
those lies
and they are particularly corrosive lies
corrosive to democracy
and corrosive to national stability now
as far as the my pillow user base
i've never met anyone who bought my
pillow pillow
could anyone really want a pillow so
badly that they would support this guy
or to put it a different way everything
i've read is that the pillows aren't
great but
if the pillows were really really good
with so many pillows out there
and available why would anybody need
this pillow
unless you're just trying to make a
political statement are there any my
pillow customers
who are not politically aligned with
with
mike pillow with mike lindell from
mypillow to me it seems like it's just
politics like if you like mike lindell
and you want to support a right-wing
company you buy his pillow
i would never even think to go and look
for pillows from political actors like
this
uh he could be selling orthopedic shoes
and it would still just be about
politics as far as i can tell if you are
a
leftist who knows mike pillows
i'm not doing that on purpose mike
lindell's uh
politics and still are getting his
pillow
i want to hear from you i want to hear
from you tell me what is so great about
the pillow
that you were ignoring his completely
ridiculous political views let me know
if you were anything like me you
probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video